yo it's kind of way out checking in
checking me out on the bootleg Kev
podcast
it's lit it's a movie let's get it
yo bootleg cat podcast man we got a
special guest in here Cowboy is in the
building what's up man yes sir what's
happening what's happening I'm chilling
brother it's good to see you it's been a
minute since I've been like five years
since I saw you yeah what have you been
up to uh working hard working hard uh
thinking smart trying to maneuver get
over obstacles yeah I mean I saw you did
Vlad like a year ago and I saw I mean
because listen you have had one of the
bigger records in the last five years
Envy me was a a moment was it triple
platinum uh it's five times now five
times Platinum my goodness
that's fire that's gotta be a dope
plaque like did you get the five times
Platinum plaque yet no you gotta you
gotta buy that one yeah yeah I'm on it
I'm gonna get I stopped at three yeah
because I stopped at four every time you
get a new certification I need to get a
new plaque it's like Jesus Christ
um but yeah I mean I I know you kind of
went through it with uh with with the
label at the time because you were with
RCA
um now you're fully independent so
congrats to that I always congratulate
artists when they're independent because
I think it's the way to go finally free
type [__] what was the uphill battle for
you with
you know because from a Fan's
perspective a lot of people like we're
having a cowboy you know what I'm saying
so what what's been going on and what
was kind of some of the uh uh you know
things you had to go through with
getting out of that deal and and trying
to move on and and get this music out
that you're sitting on
um
well I would say one of the bigger
problems was like
the back end business you know what I'm
saying like getting like different
personalities to see eye to eye things
like that to actually get the ball
rolling that was very difficult in my
situation you know what I'm saying in
terms of just like agreeing on what to
put out agreeing on when to put it out
yeah yeah so from a fans perspective it
looks like uh Carol ain't working or he
ain't he don't care about us type and
then I kind of disappeared to them
I mean that's what I that's what I I was
like what happened to Cowboy my boy had
hit me and I was like oh because I
remember you did the Vlad interview that
went viral for other reasons yeah just a
lot of the BS behind closed doors just
slowed down the consistency and the flow
yeah because people don't understand
like when you're on a major label
it is very much a mutual relationship so
in their eyes
per your contract if you turn a body of
work in and we release it I owe you
money here's an advance for that album
right so in their eyes their their
perspective is
well we got to feel good about whatever
this is we got to agree on if if we feel
strong about all these records and then
that's when you know or you know you got
to catch a moment and force their hand
almost right you know what I'm saying so
there is always that gridlock on the
major label side yeah so that's that's
what it was for yeah for sure and I and
I figured it out I got up out of there
now we working was it easy to get your
well obviously it wasn't easy to get
your release but what like well tell me
about that process of getting released
off of it um it took a couple years yeah
um took a little money
uh took a strong um
support system
because you have to buy yourself out uh
not necessarily no okay but I had to uh
just let a lot of things go yeah
if you get what I mean in terms of like
some of your music you recorded on their
dime yeah
so if like you record music on their
dime you might not ever hear that music
but do they still have the right Jesus
sorry do they still have the right to
release that music or is it just like
hey this is us you know what I'm saying
like you go do your thing yeah it's
really it's really like that I'm just
doing my own thing they ain't really
worried about the other music but I'm
sure they uh cause a hassle if I try to
like drop stuff on you yeah yeah that
makes sense I've had friends of mine who
have like been on major labels and then
they'll get with like a really big
producer like let's just use an example
Timberland or somebody right right and
then they get off of the label but they
still got all these unreleased songs
with like
these giant producers and they're like
ah
do I have risk just throwing the [__]
out there to see what happens all right
you know I mean it can work both ways it
could work out or it could be like
yeah you get a cease and desist well
right now I'm working on like uh all
fresh music yeah you know the energy
that I'm in right now how I feel right
now so no the new song is dope I watch
the videos dope dope record you're
snapping on it for sure that was one of
the ones where I was just feeling myself
you know what I'm saying but
um that's the start of it Unchained just
explaining like what I really went
through for real yeah what for people
who don't know because I saw it I mean
you lost a lot of your personal friend I
think you lost like 12 friends in a year
no eight and two eight years eight
friends in two years yeah so that's
gotta be like three of them was family
members uh older cousin uh a younger
cousin
and uh because I'm around my age it's
crazy because we we hear that same story
coming from so many people from your
city right and it's like you know G
herbo has a song called PTSD and he
talks a lot about like uh the mental
strength you have to have to be from
where he's from where you're from you
know what I'm saying and and to deal
with so much loss and so much hurt like
do you ever feel like you had an
opportunity to really mourn
um
yeah behind closed doors when you were
by yourself you know what I'm saying but
um
you grow
I mean numb to it you know what I'm
saying you get used to it I wouldn't say
numb to it because you still care but no
but it's it used to yeah I mean it's
something you can get used to if you get
there's women out here who are getting
cheated on by the same guy for a decade
who I know and I'm like well you're just
used to it at this point like you don't
even care anymore like you like [__]
happens to you and unfortunately no
matter how traumatic it is like you're
kind of conditioned to deal with it you
know what I'm saying yeah I always say
it could be worse that's I mean
everything could always be worse so [__]
100 do you ever feel like uh you have
ever like
consider maybe hitting therapy talking
out some of your [__] like that I tried
that before oh you did yeah like uh
talking to somebody all the time
it work a little bit it's cool yeah but
um
I'd rather just do music for real like
that is your therapy yeah that's what it
is I love that
um this album you're about to release is
your first album as an independent
artist right which is a big deal yeah
um this is a new space for you uh to be
who you are with already with a five
times platinum record and now you're
able to kind of move freely you're able
to kind of call the shots do what you
want to do how does it feel like like is
is it something there's got to be like a
cool
Just Energy to that yeah yeah yeah I
feel free I don't know why I keep saying
that but that's what it feels like you
feel like a a weight is off my shoulder
you know I get to see certain things you
know what I'm saying I get to move how I
want to I mean
it's just a better positive energy all
the way around you know what I'm saying
that's how I feel you know so I'm
excited for it I was gonna say what
would you say is your was your biggest
um for people who think you just
disappeared what would you attribute
that to the reason of that is it the is
it the label thing or is it just
like what was it what was what's the
reason why we haven't gotten a lot of
music from you in the last few years
yeah it's a label thing yeah it was a
label thing bro for sure is it hard to
still stay motivated if you feel like
you're kind of like no
um
I'm still living yeah you know my two
feet still move you know what I'm saying
so I mean I'm grateful for that yeah and
I can work and I can grind I can do what
I want to do still so I love it man I
ain't tripping I always stay motivated
uh your writing process are you the type
of artist because when I hear your [__]
I feel like you lay the melody first and
then you go in and fill in the lyrics is
that what you do yeah no pen nope
straight like
jobs inside I love it my homies be
laughing at me because they'd be like
what are you doing in there he's just
mumbling and I'd be like I'm just
humming you know trying to catch the
vibe yeah yeah they come back five
minutes later it's a whole song they're
like oh man that's crazy it's that quick
five minutes you're you're a beast yeah
yeah I'll be going crazy I mean you just
told me you have like 200 unreleased
songs so yeah I got a lot of release
music I'm assuming that there's gonna be
a whole lot of pressure coming from you
do you um look five years is a long time
uh from having a record that kind of
puts you on the Forefront of hip-hop for
a while right right
um do you feel like
you have to get any of those like
because fans have a short attention span
the extent I mean nowadays man I feel
like fans are extremely
finicky they're very fair weather fans
like they'll be [__] with you one day
until the next [__] comes out and right
and then it might be better or whatever
it is right for you you kind of feel
like you're a new artist all over again
like you got to kind of remind people
who you are and what you and what you're
doing and like you know
um I feel like that yeah um but every
day I get reminded why it's not that
still you know what I'm saying when I
walk into a room everybody know what it
is already yeah so
it's like somewhere in between you know
what I'm saying it's just a restart for
me but to be a fresh artist now they
know what it is already 100
um hey we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our folks at Odd Socks
baby shout out to Odd Socks man the most
comfortable socks in the world Listen
they got all the licenses if you love
chips you know what I'm saying they got
the Funyuns they got the goddamn Doritos
uh they got Godfather what's up about
Odd Socks is not only is it the most
comfortable sock in the world that you
could put on your feet but they also
just introduce their draws that's right
we got Odd Socks Basics underwear right
here which are amazing so if you um
if you just like that clean cut you know
we got the black ones or
if you're a fan of
a little bit of the uh Reese's you know
what I'm saying
look go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
the basics these are a pair of the
basics these are oh they're just so
comfortable dude like trust me when I
say all right if you're into wrestling
if you're into Transformers Power
Rangers goddamn Pepsi Coke they got both
you know what I'm saying shout out to
Odd Socks oddsocks official.com use that
promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout also got a shout out to the
family at Blue chew that's right it's
hot as hell outside what does that have
to do with Bluetooth I haven't decided
yet but I do know if you're uh dealing
with erectile dysfunction or maybe your
thing ain't thinking like it should be
thanging you know what I'm saying get
that Bluetooth same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis yes all right but it's
getting straight to your door in a very
discreet package no doctor's
appointments no doctor's visits all
right it's all online bluetooth.com all
right and this was dope about Bluetooth
uh one uh it makes your dick work like
it's never worked before we're just
being honest imagine like Barry Bonds 71
home run season but the dick form that's
how you're gonna be feeling when you're
on these blue shoes all right trust me
when I say it's a chewable form they
just drop their mint chewables as well
um there's so much to go down with
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and they'll send you your first
month for free yes you're asking me does
Bluetooth work of course it does find
out for yourself for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg all right go get you
a month of Bluetooth for free
and thank me later your wife will be
thinking your girl will be thinking me
your dick will be thinking me you know
what I mean all right let's get back to
the interview
yeah I was I told you I saw that Vlad
interview last year did you and the baby
ever work out whatever you guys had
going on internet it was just like some
comments getting left yeah yeah yeah
it's just you know it was mad in my
comments but I mean I mean at the end of
the day you try to stay out the media
you're giving your uh you were giving
your uh opinion on how you felt about
certain [__] yeah you know it is what it
is people can feel it I mean I just had
estg walk out of an interview because I
asked them about it yeah so
I saw that bro yeah you haven't walked
out yet no I'm not you cool you I
appreciate it you ain't asking me no
weird
uh man talk to me about just Chicago bro
because obviously you know there's been
so much uh I mean [__] man Dirk has a
headline in Arena tour right now
um I was just there oh in Chicago yeah
that's where I just came from now I
opened up the first day was Were You
There When the shooting had happened and
the that was the date
um after the day you weren't at that
show no I wasn't there okay uh the the
crew was there though some of the guys
was there but I went there but um the
first day was was cool I don't think it
was no shooting though I think that's
cap though I don't know I just know that
there was this video yeah I know I know
some folks was fighting and somebody
might have got cut or stabbed or
something I don't think it was no
shooting I just saw the video everyone
running and then everyone just grabbing
merch yeah yeah so it was a lot of that
going on because the show ended early
yeah so I think the fans was upset for
real or something you know was was Kodak
on that show
I don't know who was that who was there
that day I feel like codex on that door
you toured with Kodak right what was
that like
um when Kodak was fun he seems like a
fun hang yeah he was cool he was real
cool
yeah he seems like the kind of guy who
I'd like to have a beer with
that's it though that's it nothing else
I don't know what else he'd be doing
I've just met just take the beer man I
was around Kodak when we was doing shows
you know what I'm saying um he hopped on
my tour bus a few times I wanted to
record I had to look portable uh studio
with me during the setup yeah so I
recorded a song for him
would you have to drive like the Scarlet
little Scarlet like interface I had the
uh Apollo Arrow the Apollo yeah yeah
yeah I hit the Apollo Arrow
um
yeah we just vibed the whole time it was
like 40 something shows as I say like
from when you kind of popped initially
to now wait how do you feel about like
kind of the state of Chicago hip-hop
it's pretty cool a lot of females is
turning up in our city right now
um
but it's cool right a young lady from
Chicago here who was it
we just had somebody here from Chicago
it's a girl oh mellow
no
who the [__] was just here fancy Fendi
Fendi yeah yeah she's great yeah she's
uh she's she's super cool
who's mellow mellow racks is she from uh
no I'm not Miller racks mellow bucks
okay okay because there's no rack so I
think racks from like Miami or something
yeah yeah cause she's on uh YMC and B I
think are you uh doing any writing or
have you done any been doing any writing
for any other artists
um as of recently nah is that ever like
a bag you try to get into yeah yeah I
don't tapped in you know
once or twice maybe you know um I don't
gave a few artists a few records I gave
YG a record for one of his past albums
uh
I gave a few other people some records I
can't really you know say nothing can't
say the YG one you could say yeah shout
out to YG yeah because it was just you
know it was cool he hit me one time like
yo you did a song with one of my
producers I wanted
straight like that like yeah I wanna I
wanna change nothing on it or nothing I
just want to throw my verse on it keep
it moving and it's on the album boom
that's fire and I'm like I'm with it
that's dope is it hard for you to find
like uh people who
are willing to work with you now that
you're independent on the production
side that are just willing to kind of
like not work with you but like like
we're talking a little bit off the air
like the biggest part about being
independent is the headache of like
clearing [__] yeah yeah you know what
I'm saying so it's like it's almost like
they might still look at you like you
got that RCA budget behind you yeah see
that's what I was saying like I don't
think I'm somewhere in between because
people still look at me like that you
know what I'm saying they like yeah we
need 15 000. this ain't RCA yeah I'm
doing this [__] on my own just out the
pocket you know what I'm saying they
like it
you know that's what it is that's crazy
I feel like they're because I always
hear artists have certain rates like
even if you buy a feature from somebody
like the homies would be like hey I'm in
I miss uh Phoenix my hometown like I
tell people if they're independent this
is the price but if they're major this
is the price there's like the Indy and
the major price I feel like for beats
that should be the same [__] right it
should yeah but or like take a cut take
a nice cut you know like right let's
collaboration and then producers still
want a couple points
and all that extra so it's like I don't
know man you got to get um artificial
intelligence to make you some Beats
that's the thing huh I think AI can make
beats yeah isn't that happening
they can
it's not good I heard one I think I
heard a fake Timberland beat that wasn't
terrible you don't think you don't think
we're living in The Matrix bro I've
really started to think about that more
recently with some of the [__] that's
been happening yeah because I always
would be like
like when you did you see like the birds
Frozen in the air there's like hundreds
of videos of Just birds that just
stopped flying and they're just still in
the air
let me show you bro
I want to see the footage of that this
[__] is crazy
this [__] is crazy hold on you got the
birds Is that real though like oh my God
hold on look look
Birds they ain't got no more
yeah we got more water we grab water
over there let me see
oh
appreciate you brother
man get the [__] out of here
those training is no nothing
the only one who saw it
right yes
get the [__] out of here there's another
one
there's [__] Birds floating in the
air man get the [__] out of here that
[__] looks real there's people saying
that it's dimensional glitches I don't
know I don't know what that means I do
some research
I don't know bro they look crazy well
then when you see the like did you see
the government official like saying that
they're like aliens are real aliens and
[__] yeah yeah I've seen that so that
made me even really be like yeah what's
really going on right now you know yeah
I'll be on some other [__] though I
already I already be thinking there's
some other [__] going on what do you
think is going on I don't know
I don't know I just feel like she we
ain't the only ones walking around this
[__] like how we think we yeah I
think that's the facts for sure you know
what I'm saying I think they're
preparing us because I mean if you're
Christian if a lot of people walk around
say hey Christian I mean they mention a
lot of different creatures inside of
that book we read so [__] I mean what
did they wipe out the face of the Earth
uh I don't know
you know so you think it might be some
Demon [__] going on no no so like
entities you know you know they speak
about Giants all type of [__] right yeah
for sure all type of uh
non-human beings yeah sure that you'd be
like oh this is like you know some cool
like uh fairy tale [__] you know like
yeah right but some of that [__] might
be for real who knows I mean you know I
stay the [__] out of the way I get my
money if you look at some of the old
school hieroglyphics from like Egypt and
[__]
some of this [__] in those hieroglyphics
is like bro they got to see this [__] so
I'm like you know what I'm saying like
there had to be some [__] going on that
like we were privy to because
[__] just wasn't but I ain't
gonna get after aliens though
I ain't gonna get this aliens though
that right there what what's in the
hieroglyphics like the pictures of like
like alien looking [__] that
were like carved into like me I just
feel like that was a different type of
being it might be an alien to you
because you don't understand it but
I guess aliens to us right non-human yes
I mean that's kind of the definition
it's like yeah so you're right you're
right you're right you're right you're
right you're right I was going to go
into smoke I just said you good you guys
I think I like you know [__] all this
UFO like did you see what happened in
Las Vegas
there was this family in Las Vegas that
called the police because they said
there was like three like 10 foot things
in their backyard creatures right right
and what's going on with that
and so the family uh CIA came the police
came the police saw the [__] thing so
there's the cops body cam footage being
like I just saw that [__] take off from
your backyard like am I crazy am I not
the only people who saw this we were
like some Jeepers Creeper [__] so like
some like some like a uh like once the
police got there or some like whatever
craft popped out of these people's
backyard so the cops were like all
talking about it like we're not crazy we
just saw that right and then for like
the next month the uh there was black
trucks that would just line up on their
street for like and then the family was
documenting it like on Tick Tock and
[__] they're like look there's more big
SUVs outside of our house that have been
here all week
something got out of Area 51 which is in
Vegas well it's in Nevada I used to live
there so all right Area 51 wow you could
drive up to like a certain point and
then there's some [__] over there oh for
sure they have um they told me uh so I
lived in Vegas for a few years and uh
you know who Molly Maul is
bald producer used to be on Love and Hip
Hop he's made a lot of big beats yeah I
think so
um so he had he had a security guard
and the security guard was
a former
like military decorated guy right like
top-notch security guy right he was
explaining to us when he worked because
he said he worked at Area 51 as a
contractor
and he said that they had like other
soldiers behind him who had higher
clearance than them
and they like like let's say they
brought him into a room and they're like
hey you got to work on this wall
um but they were being held cat like I
guard the whole time so they wouldn't
walk anywhere else in the area you know
what I'm saying and he said that that
while he was there he saw
like a metal
or like some sort of matter that no
matter what you did to it if you if you
blew it up if you shot it if you bent it
if you tore it apart it always came back
together to the same uh form some
Transformers [__] yeah me you know who
Pooh Bear is the writer Pooh Bear he
wrote all Justin Bieber [__] me and Pooh
Bear was just like we were just
listening to this dude one night at
Molly Mall's crib high as [__] yeah
what the [__] is going on right
I can believe it though shout out my
brother Pooh Bear man I think I think
[__] like that exists hey man I just
think you know they just let us they
that's why I think they're easing us
into some [__] because they gotta kind
of ease Us in now it's like they just
can't just out of nowhere like oh no
yeah we gotta stop the interview real
quick and tell you about our folks at my
bookie man look my bookie NFL season is
approaching and you know what they just
added that I love is that early cash out
let's say you got a ticket and it's
looking great you can cash out early on
that ticket all right I love it all
right plus of course my bookie's got the
full casino going down and if you sign
up right now using the promo code
bootleg they will give you that first
deposit bonus up to a thousand dollars
all right so head over to my bookie ASAP
um look we're at uh NFL coming there's
baseball you can gamble on right now and
of course the full service casino
blackjack with the real dealer uh
roulette craps whatever you're into slot
machines you could do it and cash out
right on my bookie all right all you got
to do is sign up with that new promo
code bootleg when you sign up
trust me when I say it's a new account
they're gonna get you that uh first
deposit bonus all right so go to my
bookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpong
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
cab podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg kingpom.com and uh man trust me
the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpong.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
um uh who who's on this uh new album do
you have any features or is it just you
or it's just me I like that it's just me
I think I just I mean I flooded myself
with features yeah you know what I'm
saying it's time to just get a world of
me you know build on my fans and it's
important too because this is your first
independent album so it's like yo I'm
standing out on my own for real exactly
I like that that's where my mom come
from when is the uh project coming out
you gotta release date yet
um not an exact date give me a couple
weeks it's gonna be here it's coming
soon coming real soon how often do you
plan on just dropping now that you're
like uh you know you ain't got the red
tape the yellow tape around you from the
label I mean I say every two months
that's not bad yeah I'll say every two
months I mean a song or a project
project
but I mean I'm a forever give them
singles and I always feed them every two
months driving a project I like that why
why be independent if you ain't gonna do
it the right way
right
yo it's crazy when you're at what's the
weirdest did like because you always
hear like
when people are in major labels they get
certain features that try to get pushed
on to them they'll be like hey look we
want to get you in with this person or
hey this song is just it just just put a
verse on it and it's a hit right did
they try to do that with you over there
they didn't
most of my features came from me so they
never were like hey
try this
nah nah most of my well all of my
features came from me just like reaching
out to people people who you [__] with
yeah yeah Daddy me Dirk all I'm just
like yo hop on this for me
yeah you know who B.o.B is so back in
the day like Atlantic Records had a hard
time popping B.o.B off right which was
on there them not him because he's
extremely talented so at the time Bruno
Mars
was shopping around all these hooks
because no one knew who he was he was
just a writer
and uh what was that first B.o.B song
was it beautiful girls
so that song I go beautiful girl
what's it called nothing on you nothing
on you oh yeah okay I remember I
remember nothing on you yeah yeah yeah
so Atlantic was just trying to get
somebody to take the song Lupe Fiasco
cut on it
and then didn't like it so it should
have been Lupe's song he passed on it
well he why'd he do that I don't know
Chicago go by the way man Lupe tweet one
of the greatest rappers of all time for
someone just straight lyrics
uh and then Bob ended up with it I was
gonna say no I'll just see it but yeah I
[__] with BRB it used to be high when I
was young for sure what about the OG's
in Chicago it's happening with you like
a Lupe type of dude or yeah obviously
yeah he's the goat you know uh uh yay I
mean I type in with yay camp
um definitely tapped in with a lot of
the um
other
uh local Legends Crucial Conflict
individuals like that LEP uh bump
hey shot to Bump J yeah what about
[__] uh Do or Die
um I ain't chopped it up would you
listen to do or die growing up yeah yeah
I still listen to do that to this day I
might be cleaning up the house or
something Crucial Conflict slept on
[__] groups ever facts that
first Crucial Conflict down which you
probably weren't alive for it's called
the final tick right oh my god when they
come out what year I think that was 95
or six yeah I wasn't even born yet it
might have been 96. they had a song
called hey yeah yeah I want to show them
yeah I was probably I was like 10.
okay you were born yet though
but yeah Do or Die po pimping man what
are we talking about have you two you
know Twisters out there doing gun
classes
yeah he's like teaching people like how
to responsibly own weapons in Chicago to
protect himself so you take people and
they'll do classes like how to shoot
how to get your license
actually my my OG went to school with
twister at West oh wow
she had to twist it man what's up she
said she used to be in the back of the
bus what happened fastest way yeah fast
as hell they used to be telling me
nobody want to hit that [__] all day
bro slow that [__] down
whole career later
100 charges a lot of them all right well
look man a new project on the way yeah
Unchained Unchained congrats on your
Independence
uh we just also dropped the freestyle so
you go check that out separate YouTube
video yeah for sure appreciate you
pulling up man and I look forward to uh
to hearing the album sir
boom hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the bootleg cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hard Dean
don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at hardine in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine